und wir kommen zu zdf heute live bei
einem bombenanschlag auf eine bundeswehr
patrouille im westafrikanischen mali
sind mehrere deutsche soldaten verletzt
worden teilweise schwer
die deutsche presse agentur spricht von
zwölf verletzten andere agenturen nennen
teilweise andere zahlen dass es einen
anschlag mit mehreren verletzten
deutschen soldaten gegeben hat das ist
aber unstrittig dass hat die bundeswehr
inzwischen bestätigt wir warten auf
genauere informationen der
bundesverteidigungsministerium annegret
kramp karrenbauer sie soll in den
nächsten minuten vor die presse treten
ersten erkenntnissen zufolge handelt es
sich bei dem angriff um einen
selbstmordanschlag und da gucken wir
gerade nochmal auf die karte wo das
genau war laut der uno mission ist ein
fahrzeug in einem camp nahe der
ortschaft tag kind detoniert der ort
liegt etwa 150 kilometer nördlich von go
wo die bundeswehr im rahmen der un
friedensmission - stationiert ist von
dort aus werden patrouillen dann zur
aufklärung ins land geschickt und wir
sprechen mit zu unserem korrespondenten
der in afrika genau genommen mit dem
krüger in nairobi die man sich natürlich
die erste frage was ist der aktuelle
kenntnisstand was weiß man bislang über
das geschehen
es ist tatsächlich im moment noch nicht
so viel was wir wissen dass es eben in
der anmoderation schon gesagt das
scheint bisher gesichert zu sein dass es
einen selbstmord-anschlag gegeben haben
soll auf eine fahrzeugkolonne oder eine
fahrzeug patrouille der bundeswehr die
im rahmen der un-mission in mali dort
unterwegs gewesen ist es gab dabei
mehrere verletzte der genaue schweregrad
dieser verletzung auch das können wir im
moment noch nicht genau sagen und auch
die höhe
du hast die verschiedenen zahlen genannt
darüber gibt es im moment noch keine
gesicherten erkenntnisse wir hoffen dass
das dann im laufe der folgenden pkw
etwas deutlicher wird klar ist auf jeden
fall dass dieser einsatz in dem die
deutschen bundeswehrsoldaten und
soldaten dort oben in nord mali im
moment stehen einer der gefährlichsten
der welt ist genau so wird er auch
bezeichnet dieser un einsatz dieser
friedenseinsatz der un mission in mali
gilt als der gefährlichste welt
und genau das ist im moment das was wir
jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt dazu sagen
können dem ich würde dich gerne noch ein
bisschen zu den hintergründen dieses
einsatzes fragen sehe allerdings gerade
mit dem anderen auge dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium strammen
schrittes auf die mikrofone zumarschiert
und ich glaube es wäre jetzt besser wir
würden das gespräch dann später
fortsetzen vielen dank schon mal für
diese erste einschätzung frau kam
karrenbauer wie gesagt ist auf dem weg
vor die presse und wir erwarten
natürlich darauf was sie gleich noch mal
sagen wird ob sie die zahlen bestätigen
kann bzw
natürlich auch wie es den verletzten
soldaten geht sehr verehrten damen und
herren herzlichen dank dass sie hier auf
die hardthöhe gekommen sind
leider haben uns heute nachrichten von
einem selbstmordanschlag auf das
deutsche - man kontingent in mali
erreicht und ich möchte sie und die
öffentlichkeit über die situation
informieren
der anschlag fand um 8 uhr 28
mitteleuropäischer zeit statt er fand
statt 180 kilometer nordöstlich von
kabul betroffen sind zwölf deutsche
soldaten und ein weiterer us-soldat der
mission minustah
diese soldaten sind verwundet worden
davon drei schwer
die rettungskette so wie wir sie vor ort
aufgebaut haben hat gegriffen und alle
verwundeten wurden mit hubschraubern aus
dem betreffenden bereich evakuiert die
medizinische versorgung läuft derzeit
sie läuft sowohl in der deutschen in der
französischen aber auch in der
chinesischen sanitäts einrichtung in
gang
zwei der schwerverletzten sind in einem
stabilen zustand
ein dritter wird zur stunde noch
operiert ihm gelten unsere besonderen
gedanken meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
die militärischen operationen vor ort
sind noch nicht abgeschlossen
denn es geht zum einen darum alle
verletzten bestmöglich zu versorgen
und es geht darum alle soldatinnen und
soldaten die noch vor ort am
anschlagsort sind jetzt so schnell und
so sicher wie möglich in das feldlager
nach kairo zurück zu bringen
darauf konzentrieren wir uns heute mit
ganzer kraft für den transport den
rücktransport der verwundeten nach
deutschland haben wir die entsprechenden
vorkehrungen getroffen ein
entsprechendes evakuierungs flugzeug ist
in bereitschaft um die schwer
verwundeten in die heimat auszufliegen
sobald ihr zustand dies zulässt der
a400m der entsprechend ausgerüstet ist
wird heute nacht direkt nach kabul
fliegen und wir hoffen dann in den
frühen morgenstunden die ersten schwer
verletzten nach hause bringen zu können
alle anderen verletzten sollen dann im
zuge der nächsten stunden und tage
folgen für uns und deswegen trete ich
auch jetzt erst vor die presse war heute
besonders wichtig dass wir zuerst die
angehörigen informieren konnten und das
ist bis auf eine familie auf gelungen
und ich darf mich bei all denjenigen im
parlamentarischen bereich aber auch in
den medien bedanken die bisher mit ihren
meldungen sehr zurückhaltend waren auch
mit rücksicht auf diese familien
das ist es was ich bis hierher sagen
kann und sie werden alle verständnis
dafür haben dass sich unsere ganze kraft
jetzt vor allen dingen darauf
konzentriert die verwundeten gute
versorgung schnellstmöglich nach hause
zu bringen
aber auch alle anderen soldatinnen und
soldaten vom anschlagsort sicher nach
kairo zurück zu bringen
über alle weiteren fragen
die es ja auch mit recht gibt nämlich
was die hintergründe sind wer hinter dem
anschlag steckt was das für die
militärische situation bedeutet was es
möglicherweise für die mission bedeutet
wie die situation wir uns auch in den
nächsten tagen sicherlich befassen
werden aber nicht heute
heute ist der tag an dem wir vor allen
dingen bei den verletzten kameraden sind
bei ihren familien und bei all unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten die im einsatz
sind in mali bei - marco tm aber auch
sonstwo in der welt ich selbst halte im
moment vor allen dingen über das
einsatzführungskommando kontakt zu
marley und ich werde in den nächsten
tagen sobald es die situation vor ort zu
lässt selbst auch mit dem
einsatzkontingent reden und mir die
informationen noch einmal geben lassen
dass wir dann auch der moment sein wo
wir sicherlich detaillierter die
öffentlichkeit weiter informieren werden
dafür bitte ich um ihr verständnis und
darf mich für ihre zurückhaltung auch im
namen der angehörigen und aller
betroffenen soldatinnen und soldaten
bedanken
der anschlag heute macht auf eine sehr
dramatische und schreckliche art und
weise deutlich dass der eid den
soldatinnen soldaten der bundeswehr
schwören dass sie dieses land
verteidigen dass sie in den einsatz
gehen und dass sie zur not auch bereit
sind ihre gesundheit und ihr leben
einzusetzen
nicht nur leere worte sind sie sind
realität und sie können jederzeit
realität werden so wie das heute leider
der fall ist wie es in den gedanken in
unseren herzen in unseren gebeten bei
diesen soldatinnen und soldaten bei
ihren familien und wir hoffen dass alle
wieder gesund werden
vielen herzlichen dank
soweit also das statement der
bundesverteidigungsminister in annegret
kramp karrenbauer sie hat im
wesentlichen bestätigen können was wir
vorher schon gemeldet hatten dass also
zwölf deutsche soldaten betroffen sind
bei diesem anschlag in mali ein weiterer
aus einer anderen un nationen drei
schwer verwundete auf deutscher seite
zwei davon stabil
einer wird wohl noch operiert und diese
verletzten personen sollen dann mit
einem flugzeug nach möglichkeit morgen
ausgeflogen werden wir sprechen mit
unserem korrespondenten mit dem leiter
des hauptstadtstudios in berlin mit theo
koll er sitzt da und hört mich glaube
ich sehr schön dass du bei uns in der
sendung dabei bist der du hast gerade
das statement auch der kampf und der
kanzlerin soll schon das ist nicht der
bundesverteidigungsministerium gehört
und deine einschätzung dazu würde mich
natürlich interessieren wie wirklich auf
dich also sie hat natürlich auch zu
verstehen gegeben warum das
verteidigungsministerium oder sie in
personen sich so spät gemeldet haben
das war hier natürlich das große
rätselraten aber sie hat klar gemacht
dass es ihr wichtig gewesen sei
verständlicherweise erst mal die
angehörigen zu informieren
deswegen hat man so spät dann auch die
öffentlichkeit informiert deswegen gab
es auch diese vielen unterschiedlichen
zahlen die hier durch die agenturen
geisterten also das ganze ist natürlich
ein schwieriges ein schwieriges
geschehen denn wir haben natürlich eine
debatte um die auslandseinsätze
afghanistan
da werden aktuell die soldaten
zurückgezogen
maly ist der gefährlichsten einsatz
weltweit die deutschen sind mit maximal
1100 soldaten beteiligt ich glaube
aktuell sind es um die 900 und der
einsatz in mali ist brandgefährlich war
vor einiger zeit mit der kanzlerin dort
in dem lager und da wurde ein
sehr klar vor augen geführt wie
gefährlich die lage ist der anflug war
schon mit mit schusssicherer weste weil
möglicherweise das flugzeug an einem
anflug beschlossen werden könnte also
die soldaten sind dort in einer sehr
gefährlichen situation diese ganze sahel
zone ist eine zone die besonders im
druck islamistischer kräfte die zum teil
aus libyen kommen zum teil sich dort
versammeln al qaida und andere
islamischer staat und wird auch gesehen
diese ganze zone als ein extrem fragiles
gebiet und die frage vor der die ganzen
nation stehen vor allem auch die
franzosen die ja da noch sehr viel
stärker engagiert sind sehr viel mehr
auch soldatische opfer zu verzeichnen
haben wie geht es da weiter
bleibt man dort vor ort nimmt man diese
opfer in kauf so wie heute die anschläge
um diese region um die regierungen dort
zu stabilisieren oder entzieht man sich
irgendwann zurück weil man nach vielen
jahren einsatz dort sieht man erreicht
eigentlich zu wenig ja die debatte wird
jetzt mit sicherheit weiter an fahrt
gewinnen nach diesem anschlag heute es
gibt ja bereits erste reaktionen aus
berlin unter anderem von dietmar bartsch
dem fraktionsvorsitzenden der linken im
bundestag hören wir mal rein
aber meine damen und herren wir haben
von dem furchtbaren anschlag in mali
gehört natürlich sind unsere gedanken
zuallererst bei den soldaten bei ihren
angehörigen und bei den helferinnen und
helfern ist ein furchtbarer anschlag der
nochmal die gefährlichkeit der
auslandseinsätze der bundeswehr zeigt
wir sind der auffassung dass die
nächsten abgeordneten des deutschen
bundestages sehr grundsätzlich und sehr
prinzipiell über die einsätze der
deutschen soldaten nachdenken und neu
entscheiden sollten
ja so war das statement also von dietmar
bartsch dass die linke nun eine
pazifistische grundhaltung hat ist
nichts neues aber was glaubst du theorie
wird jetzt diese äußerungen ähnliche
forderungen in berlin diskutiert werden
also es gab auch stimmen aus der linken
die gesagt haben dass marie droht das
zweite afghanistan zu werden das ist für
die linke in der tat keine überraschende
position die grünen haben sich sehr viel
zurückhaltender geäußert und gesagt man
darf jetzt nicht in einer solchen
situation an einem solchen tag da
irgendwelche schnellschüsse in
anführungsstrichen verkünden sondern
muss darüber nachdenken aber ich glaube
die große problematik die wird bleiben
also deutschland steht mit seiner
außenpolitik im grunde vor immer
größeren anforderungen wir sollen uns
stärker einbringen in der welt nicht
zuletzt der us präsident forderte und
auch die gesamtlage der europäischen
länder fordern dass wir uns stärker
einbringen als bundesdeutsche und
insofern ist molly exemplarisch willmann
und kann man dort solcher
auslandseinsätze mit all den gefahren
die damit verbunden sind über sehr lange
zeit durchhalten und und dann in kauf
nehmen dass solche dinge wie heute
passieren andré wüstner der vorsitzende
des bundeswehrverbandes hat sich auch
geäußert gegenüber dem redaktions
netzwerk deutschland er fordert unter
anderem mehr schutz für die
einsatzkräfte und spricht sich auch noch
mal ganz offen dafür aus dass auch
bewaffnete drohnen zum einsatz kommen
sollten könnte auch diese debatte jetzt
wieder an fahrt gewinnen
ja die läuft ja auch schon also die
verteidigungsministerien wollte ja
bewaffnete drohnen anschaffen das ist
bisher nicht gelungen gab es keine
mehrheit für aber das ist sicherlich
eine eine wichtige debatte
es gab zunächst mal eine mehrheit dafür
den auslandseinsatz in mali zu
verlängern bis mai kommenden
der muss dann jeweils wieder verlängert
werden und ich denke dass je nachdem wie
die nächste koalition aussieht diese
debatte dann auch nochmal geführt wird
generell theo noch mal ganz kurz deine
einschätzung wie würdest du das jetzt
beurteilen wird deutschland seine
präsenz was uno beteiligungen an geht
über denken grundsätzlich überdenken
oder gibt es da nach wie vor keine
gründe ernsthafte alternativen irgendwie
in erwägung zu ziehen
ich glaube nicht ich glaube nicht dass
ein solcher anschlag dazu führt das ist
im grunde eingepreist so so furchtbar
das klingt wenn man dort im einsatz ist
und die franzosen haben da sehr viele
soldaten verloren
dann weiß man wie gefährlich das ist und
frau kramp karrenbauer hat ja eben noch
mal daran erinnert dass die soldaten mit
ihren eid im grunde ihr leben und ihre
gesundheit bereit sind einzubringen also
ich glaube nicht dass der anschlag das
gravierend etwas daran ändern wird an
der diskussion aber die große diskussion
wie stark bringen wir uns ein und da
geht im grunde die tendenz ja eher in
mehr
die wird sicherlich zu führen sollen
welche erwartungen glaubst du haben da
auch die partner nach wie vor eben an
deutschland was ist für ihn schon
angesprochen die usa erwarten auch immer
mehr von deutschland materiell also an
zuwendung aber eben auch an an mitteln
insgesamt auch das wird wahrscheinlich
jetzt dadurch nicht weniger werden
sondern die erwartungen an deutschland
werden hoch bleiben
ja ich meine wir haben das ist ja die
große debatte um die zwei prozent
dass wir auch zugesagt haben wie alle
nato-mitglieder 2 prozent des
inlandsproduktes einzubringen
verteidigung und insofern glaube ich
dass wir da unter druck geraten weiter
denn wir liegen deutlich darunter
und die forderung und die bleibt
bestehen
joe biden hat das ja auch relativ klar
gemacht und ich vermute mal dass
dass die bei allem bei allen konsens den
es gibt mit der neuen administration in
der neuen regierung in washington dass
die erwartungen und die bundesregierung
da nicht geringer werden
theo koll war dass der leiter des
hauptstadtstudios in berlin vielen dank
dafür dass du uns heute zur verfügung
gestanden hast und wir haben die
möglichkeit noch mal ganz kurz rüber zu
gehen nach afrika das klingt irgendwie
so salopp aber ist natürlich aufwendig
wir haben aber tim kröger immer noch für
uns parat stehen in nairobi in diesem
fall team und ich hätte gerne noch ein
paar hintergründe von dir bekommen zu
diesem einsatz im minus war der
bundeswehr in mali als wir haben gerade
schon von theo erfahren das ist ein
unheimlich gefährlicher einsatz
vielleicht kannst du uns den auch noch
mal ein bisschen einordnen wie lange
geht er schon und was zeichnet diesen 1
oder last beschreibt diesen einsatz was
charakterisiert ihnen also dieser
einsatz geht seit 2013
seitdem sind auch bundeswehrsoldaten vor
ort und das ganze beruht ja also der
hintergrund ist dass es 2012 in mali
einen islamisten aufstand gegeben hat
der damals mit der französischen armee
und der manischen armee zurückgedrängt
worden ist aber das hat noch lange nicht
für sicherheit für sicherheit gesorgt
dort oben in nord mali deswegen diese
un-mission die im wesentlichen das ziel
hat den frieden dort oben zu bewahren es
gibt einen friedensschluss der
kriegsparteien denen die un truppen dort
13.000 sind es insgesamt im land aus
verschiedenen nationen überwachen sollen
und dann hat natürlich jede einheit in
dem fall die bundeswehr eigene aufgaben
die bundeswehr sehr stark in der
aufklärung dort oben engagiert das sind
zum beispiel drohnen gewesen und
programme mit denen sie luftaufklärung
betrieben haben aber das sind eben auch
patrouillen also beispielsweise gibt es
ja dieses kann castor das kann das camp
in grau wo die meisten der bundeswehr
soldatinnen und soldaten stationiert
sind
das ist ein schwer gesichertes feldlager
von wo aus dann diese patrouillen
staaten meistens sind das gepanzerte
fahrzeuge und ich habe selber eine
solche patrone 2017 miterlebt die
soldatinnen und soldaten fahren dann
raus oft auch über nacht
mehrere tage sprechen mit der
bevölkerung versuchten informationen zu
bekommen über die lage
das kann durchaus einen gewissen radius
auch haben wir haben ja gehört dass
dieser anschlag 180 kilometer nördlich
vom gas stattgefunden hat das gibt uns
einen eindruck wie weit sie sich dann
auch von diesem lager internen das ist
so ungefähr das was die bundeswehr dort
vor ort macht und warum ist jetzt die
lage in mali so fragil wie könnte man
die situation dort beschreiben die lage
ist so fragil weil es einfach sehr viele
verschiedene islamistische gruppierungen
gibt die nord mal die mittlerweile auch
in zentral miley mittlerweile eigentlich
auch in der gesamten region aktiv sind
das sind zum einen islamistischen
gruppierungen die mit al qaida verbunden
sind das kind aber auch islamistische
gruppierungen die mit dem islamischen
staat verbunden sind und dann kommt dazu
dass diese gruppierung sich
untereinander mittlerweile auch zum teil
bekämpfen
dazu kommen schmuggler kriminalität dazu
kommt mittlerweile auch schwere
ethnische konflikte das alles führt zu
dieser gesamt unsicheren situation die
dazu geführt hat dass die un-mission in
mali als die gefährlichste der welt geht
jetzt ist es ja so dass es gerade im
letzten jahr allein zwei militärputsch
gegeben hat oder putsche jetzt stellt
man sich natürlich die frage das militär
wird ja eigentlich von den un nationen
die dort sind ausgebildet aber das
militär wird ja nicht zum putzen
ausgebildet denkt man so wie kann das
sein
genau das ist die große frage wie diese
verschiedenen missionen die es in mali
gibt verschiedenen militärischen
missionen jetzt weitergehen bei dieser
putsch aus dem august 2020 und jetzt der
putsch im putz der vor wenigen wochen
stattgefunden hat was das für
auswirkungen hat in der tat jetzt ist im
moment so dass sich anfang juni einer
der militärischen führer als zweiter zum
präsidenten hat machen lassen er hat
zwar versichert dass der
übergangsprozess der demokratischen
übergangsprozess weiter geben soll und
das ist demokratische wahlen anfang
kommenden jahres geben soll aber es gibt
natürlich die große frage wie vor allem
die europäer jetzt darauf reagiert
dass sie dort mit einer armee
zusammenarbeiten die pushen
beispielsweise ist die bundeswehr auch
engagiert in der sogenannten
europäischen ausbildungsmission wo
konkret die magischen streitkräfte
ausgebildet werden diese mission wurde
gerade von 450 auf 600 mann und frauen
noch einmal erweitert und sie sollte
effektiver gestartet wer gestaltet
werden das heißt mehr ans kampfgeschehen
ran er auch nach zentral miley das
könnte ganz eventuell auch diese mission
noch einmal gefährlicher machen
allerdings das war die reaktion auf
diesen letzten ko sind jetzt
mittlerweile alle vorbereitungen
offenbar erstmal unter vorbehalt
gestellt worden
und es gibt noch eine andere sehr
massive auswirkung nämlich die einzige
militärische präsenz in mali die moment
wirklich anti terrorkampf betreibt das
sind die franzosen mit der mission
balkan und im präsident micro hat als
reaktion auf den letzteren putsch gesagt
dass diese mission jetzt erst mal
eingestellt langsam zurückgefahren und
dann irgendwann völlig beendet werden
soll
dann soll es eine wie auch immer
geartete weitere präsenz und auch
strategie geben aber wohl so hört man
mit deutlich weniger truppen was das
alles dann für die gesamtlage in mali
und auch für die präsenz der bundeswehr
truppen vor ort bedeutet ist die große
frage
ja also eine ziemlich verfahrene lage
und einfache lösungen sind da ganz
offensichtlich nicht in sicht tim kröger
war das für uns aus nairobi aber mit
ganz offensichtlich auch profunden
kenntnissen zur lage in mali vielen dank
für die zeit und vielen dank für die
antworten
vielen dank fürs zu sehen und wir sagen
für den moment auf wiedersehen und
melden uns dann wieder beim nächsten
liveshow ist anschauen